we've also heard today that big uk
businesses including bt thames water the
co-op and nestle have called on the
government to phase out gas power by
2035 that's just 14 years away so is it
achievable um vicky what do you think 40
of the uk's electricity
generation comes from gas plants do you
think we can phase it out by 2035
i think it's going to be rather
difficult the reason why they're calling
for it of course
is because of the increase that we're
just seeing in gas prices there is a
belief that we don't have enough
security to supply and therefore we need
to move into something else now the
question is are they asking for this
because it's clean or are they asking
for this because they really want to
make sure that whatever power there is
comes easily to the very sectors that
need it and you know it could be a
combination of the two which uh it would
be interesting but it costs a lot to
move from where we are now in terms of
using different type of fuel if you like
in those very heavy energy intensive
sectors like for example steels and
chemicals and cement where the costs are
very very great in terms of moving into
something else and they use huge amount
of heat for the process of production
that they've got at present so it is
going to be difficult it will require
a lot more investment than what we've
got planned at present
um so what do you think given what we're
seeing at the moment um not having to
rely on gas imports it sounds like it
would be an excellent thing
uh yes it would be and uh i don't think
it's that much of a surprise that these
household names have called for it
because
the government's statutory body on uh
advising and among climate change the
committee on climate change actually
says that unabated gas should be over by
2035. so it's actually consistent with
what the messages that the government is
getting and what we are seeing
here is is a kind of a difference
between what the
most cost effective and the least
disruptive
way forward that the committee on
climate changes are laying out and the
policies that have been put in place and
not been put in place in a timely manner
to get us there and
i think on fossil fuels
there was a great report out last week
from oxford university that showed that
for fossil fuels
that are the costs that are adjusted for
inflation
they have not got any cheaper over the
last
140 years
whereas renewables have been decreasing
in price incredibly rapidly they are 2
000 times
cheaper today than they were
50 years ago so it makes sense to get
onto renewables
and off fossil fuels and vicky is
correct in that there are some
industrial processes that require uh
huge amounts of heat but carbon-free
production of steel has already started
in sweden and the uk needs to get at the
beginning of the head of that curve and
move to those green industries to get
those green jobs and a transition away
from these dirty heavy industries
towards green industries but vicky it
does all come down to money doesn't it
getting there the lesser even says the
move would require a significantly
greater level of investment in
renewables that has been possible to
date and that's 14 billion pounds a year
who's gonna foot that bill
well that's a very good point i think
what the government needs to do right
now
is to share the risk if you like with
the private sector there is a lot of
money around that can be invested in
green technology as we've seen you know
there's
people are buying up uh companies like
there's no tomorrow and they are
prepared to support list of governments
who are trying to raise money so there
is a lot of liquidity around that can be
used properly to support a cleaner
economy though the problem is that the
risks involved with technology are still
very great so governments i'm afraid
have to step in like they're doing in
the eu i think we need to do that in the
uk as well and share that risk and give
a sort of guarantee to whoever may want
to go down that investment rate but
without that i think there would be a
lot of reluctance to engage in something
which may just lead to no results at all
for individual investors
okay vicky price simon lewis thank you
so much it's been fantastic talking to
you have a great weekend thank you
that's everything from us for this week
but do stay tuned because coming up next
on sky news tonight ministers hold
crisis talks on how the national
shortage of lorry drivers can be
resolved as queues at several petrol
stations continue to grow thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]
you